des guère bavard
quatre ans là-bas ça ne répond pas comme
ça et tout ça ça vient des lic de
l'argent de prix
et vous en aurez d'autres non on en
tournait pas là bas
[Musique]
comme il est et où frère à l'arrière
le plus important c'est qu'ils soient en
vie
heureusement qui a ses coups et je
mettrai il paraît qu'elle est jolie
jolie demoiselle
il va retrouver la parole c'est juste
une question de temps ah oui bien sûr
maintenant voyez aussi ça dépend de vous
[Musique]
tu voudras pas bien en afrique avec man
tu verrais des choses en tant pays des
appels ou l'enfance au manteau feu vous
savez je le comprends ça va râler
redondantes abrogé vieux ans
il y aura plus qu on vient comment les
sourires aux lèvres comme si on rentrait
d'une partie de campagne et je sais très
classieuse et j'ai vu le truc est ce que
tu as pu étudier des dents la france et
personne c'est personne pesant
[Musique]
pourquoi tu lui fais pas ta demande je
viens avec toi
[Musique]